Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus heute schon wieder im
Studio hier in Hamburg freue mich ja
kübelt sagt man hier in Strömen ist
unvorstellbar
geht
klassische Hamburger Wetter ja aber wir
hatten so lange nicht ja ich habe
zweimal in Hamburg gelebt ja für wenige
Monate und beides mal kann ich mich
nicht an Sonne erinnern aber das war
eine 90
Richard spannend wir haben viel zu
besprechen und ich habe über dich schon
wieder gelesen ja du hast endlich
eingesehen dass die Russen diesen Krieg
verlieren und du bist Klima Leutner
geworden ja gefühlt auch das letzte
Woche es ist Wahnsinn erzähle einmal ich
habe das gelesen du hast in Düsseldorf
ne ständhausen ja so eine Interview
Reihe live Interview genau und dachte
warte mal was ist neu das hat doch
Richard hier im Podcast schon erzählt
das dazu auch in der Sendung erzählt
also wir haben ja mehrfach schon darüber
gesprochen natürlich also es ging um
eine Aussage am Anfang des Krieges als
die Militärexperten alle sagten der
Krieg geht ganz kurz und dauert
vielleicht zwei Wochen und ich mir die
Frage gestellt habe welchen Sinn es
macht sich zu verteidigen wenn man
sowieso verliert ne und wir haben häufig
darüber gesprochen und ist ja völlig
klar das war halt unter militärischem
Aspekt eine totale Fehlannahme so aber
das habe ich damals zu dir gesagt als
wir die Fernsehsendung hatten dass ich
hier im Podcast gesagt ich habe dir auch
die Größe der Welt ja genau ich habe
noch einige Sätze mehr gesagt die kommen
dann aber nicht in die Agenturmeldung
ich habe natürlich auch darauf
hingewiesen auf die von dem
Oberbefehlshaber der Armee der
amerikanischen Armee so geschätzten etwa
200.000 Toten und schwer verletzen
Wahnsinn ja dass dieser gleiche general
meint dass der Krieg mit militärischen
Mittel nicht zu gewinnen sein und auch
auf die Notwendigkeit von Verhandlungen
hingewiesen also alles das was ich auch
sonst immer gemacht habe das taucht
allerdings alles in der Agenturmeldung
dann nicht mehr auf so Arbeiten die ein
oder anderen Journalisten in diesem Land
ja es ist die Verkürzung ne und ich weiß
nicht wie es Dir dabei immer geht
deswegen spreche ich das Thema auch kurz
an ich hatte das letzte Woche auch wir
hatten Carla Rochel bei uns eine junge
Frau junge
Psychologiestudentin aus Leipzig wenn
ich das richtig erinnere sehr
sympathische junge Frau die ich auch
persönlich so mochte weil sie eine sehr
angenehme Art hat ihre Dinge zu
vermitteln und ich wir sprachen dann
über das was die machen die gehört zur
sogenannten letzten Generation also
klebt sich regelmäßig auf Straßenfest
und so weiter das Thema unseres letzten
Podcasts ja wieder Ungehorsam und ich
war sehr neugierig darauf mal zu
erfahren wie diese Leute ticken und
warum sie tun was sie tun und was mir
auch viel Wahrheit und darüber wollte
ich kurz mit dir sprechen
da finden immer wieder so
apokalyptisches Szenarien von ihrer
Seite sie sprach sofort in einer der
ersten Einlassungen davon dass
Milliarden Menschen werden jetzt sterben
und so weiter und dann kam irgendwann
der Satz so ich habe es nicht mehr
hundertprozentig genau im Kopf aber so
sinngemäß die Wissenschaft und 4 Grad
und so weiter und ich sagte dann
irgendwann nee also die Wissenschaft
gibt es in dem Zusammenhang auch nicht
wie in allen anderen Fällen auch nicht
und vier Grad das ist ein Szenario das
kann eintreten wenn wir einfach die
Dinge weiterlaufen lassen und habe sie
dann darauf hingewiesen habe mir gesagt
ich die dieses Menschenbild tut mir so
weh da sitzt eine 20-jährige weißt du
die ihr ganzes Leben vor sich hat und
ich habe mich gar nicht getraut die
Frage zu stellen ob sie irgendwann mal
planen eine Familie zu gründen oder
Kinder zu kriegen weil ich die Antwort
schon Garant habe und die mir sagt wir
werden alle sterben und dann brauchen
wir auch keinen Monat mehr ja und dieses
apokalyptische das war das was ich
sozusagen beklagt habe und sagte und
habe noch mal Versuch darauf hinzuweisen
dass er die Geschichte der Menschheit
auch eine Geschichte der Anpassung ist
wir waren als Spezies deswegen so
erfolgreich weil wir uns so erfolgreich
immer wieder angepasst haben und schon
warst du genau damit habe ich natürlich
nicht gesagt dass wir natürlich ein
ernsthaftes Problem haben dass wir ganz
ganz viel tun müssen und dass wir ganz
häufig auch darüber reden und das dass
ich das aus eigener Anschauung auch
kenne und so weiter und dass das mir ein
riesiges Anliegen ist seit langer langer
Zeit aber dann wurde diese Äußerung aus
dem Zusammenhang gelöst
sofort aber das war nicht mein Thema
mich hat mich hat er
beunruhigt etwas anderes und da und da
kommt vielleicht auch der Vater in mir
durch ich hatte weißt du im Kontrast
dazu am nächsten Tag Herbert dies der
mit dem Klima und der Art und Weise wie
CO2 in die Luft geblasen wurde als
ehemaliger volkswagenchef durchaus was
zu tun hat oh ja ja und es ist auch eben
die Aussage damals stammte das ein
Prozent des weltweiten CO2 Ausstoßes auf
das Konto auf allein neuen Volkswagen
genau größter Automobilkonzern der Welt
auch interessant übrigens war mir auch
nicht so richtig klar bis zu dem
Zeitpunkt ich glaube die Zahl ist 98 98
Prozent aller Autos von VW sind im
Moment noch Verbrenner also der Eindruck
der durch geschicktes Marketing und
durch das ständige berichten von neuen
E-Modellen entsteht ist VW ist jetzt
eine elektrischer Konzern das werden sie
bald sein und ich nehme das auch sehr
ernst was die da tun und ich finde es
gut dass sie das tun aber so ein Tanker
um Touristen
und sagt nee wir haben wir haben da kein
Problem wir kriegen das in Griff und
also wir haben die Technologie und was
ich meine ist der war so dem Leben
zugewandt und so optimistisch und das
kontrastierte so stark mit dieser jungen
Frau von 20 Jahren aber ich finde den
Kontrast gut ja also ich glaube alles
hat sein Recht in dieser Diskussion ich
muss ja sagen wie war ich denn drauf mit
18 also als ich 18 war
reden wir jetzt über die Zeit 1983 so
das war die Zeit des Höhepunktes der
Friedensbewegung ja und die auch noch
zum Teil gespeist war aus dem aus der
akw-bewegung es gab vor den Atomunfall
in harrisberg es kann die
Friedensbewegung in gleichen Jahr 83 was
wir damals noch nicht wussten ich glaube
es war sogar 83 ereignete sich ein
Zwischenfall der fast tatsächlich den
Dritten Weltkrieg ausgelöst hätte wenn
damals dieser russische Oberst ja den
roten Knopf gedrückt hätte und nicht
sich nicht gesagt hätte das mache ich
mal nicht genau also musst du sagen
denken ne als in Polen das Ding darunter
kam naja wo man dachte
Besonnenheit Besonnenheit ja ganz
langsam genau das ist nicht die Stunde
der hypermoral das ist die Stunde der
ganz langsam
im Hintergrund nicht politisch politisch
gab es Leute die ganz schnell ja ganz
schnell ist Statements rausgehauen haben
auch viel zu schnell maria hat eine
Strate Zimmermann unter anderem ja und
äh dabei
sogar dabei
also gleich vom Bündnisfall gesprochen
hat in Polen waren auch nicht gerade
ruhig in der Situation
in der Tat ausgesprochen besonnen genau
und das ist gut
zu sehen dass diese Besonnenheit da ist
genau aber worauf ich hinaus will ist
ich meine ich habe damals auch gesagt es
geht um alles ja also wir stehen in
einer
apokalyptischen Situation also genau das
gleiche ja jeden Moment kann der
Atomkrieg losgehen gleichzeitig gab es
diese umweltreporte Global 2000 wo
erzählt wurde dass im Jahr 2000 die Welt
in fürchterlichen Umständen sein würde
und ich gedacht habe wir müssen wir
müssen wir müssen wir müssen wir haben
keine Millisekunde zu finden und das
natürlich Moral in dem Alter immer Moral
in welchem Maßstab ist genau absolute
Moral wenn man 18 ist und hell und wach
und ich denke wenn man im Alter was kann
in meinem Alter ist dann gibt es auch
relativ ja
dann gibt es vor allen Dingen die
Überlegung wohin absolute Moral führt
dass man also immer versucht zu
überlegen ist quasi dieser dieser
absolute moralische Maßstab Ziel führend
oder ist ja nicht zielführend
und ich könnte jetzt ein kompliziertes
Wort benutzen ja ich mache das mal es
komplizierteste Wort das hier in diesem
Podcast gefallen ist sagt es gibt so
etwas wie ein Imperativ zur
Minimalisierung von
universalisierbarkeitsforderungen
das heißt also man muss selbst wenn man
im großen denkt ja immer in der Lage
sein die Probleme die im Weltmaßstab
sich stellen auch wieder kleiner zu
machen ja es gibt sozusagen eine innere
Verpflichtung dazu sich von der
Apokalypse zu befreien aber nicht aber
das ist das was
der apokalyptisch ist musst du zum Arzt
der muss zum Arzt und er mit 20 nicht
verstanden
das ist genau der Punkt ich ich mochte
das weißt Du das Ding ist und dass das
ist dann diese Verkürzung die mich auch
tatsächlich dann persönlich verletzt so
dieses Ding der da geht jetzt der alte
weiße Mann ja ist dann immer sofort die
Schublade die aufgeht ja der geht jetzt
auf dieses arme Mädchen los war gar
nicht so sondern das war aus einer aus
einer empathischen Haltung heraus ja mir
hat das einfach leid getan weil ich
dachte Mensch ich habe selber Kinder und
was was ist denn die Konsequenz daraus
ja und ich habe gemerkt wie leicht und
wie schnell es geht dass man sozusagen
diese ich immer die hat ihr Studium
erstmal eine Nagel gehängt und macht das
jetzt quasi hauptberuflich weil es ihr
intrinsisch ein echtes Anliegen ist und
ganz ehrlich ich meine jemand der sich
für eine Klimafrage ernsthaft engagiert
und alles bereit ist dafür zu tun und
vielleicht auch mal den ein oder anderen
ihren Weg geht ja der ist mir doch alle
mal lieber als jemand der sich bei
Youtube oder insta von morgens bis
abends mit Schminktipps beschäftigt
bitte dich unbedingt
Kinder in die Welt das ist der Punkt
aber die die Frage ist halt diese also
da ist ja auch unzweifelhaft Ideologie
im Spiel und dann wird dann sofort
gesagt der der Land ist der dämlich und
der soll doch mal den Klima Report lesen
und so weiter mit
habe ich an irgendeiner Stelle
geleugnet oder negiert das ist da ein
ernsthaftes Problem große Probleme halt
daran dass wir das Ding nicht nur in den
Griff kriegen werden wir müssen es in
den Griff kriegen und ich wie wäre und
ich habe in dem Zusammenhang halt auf
Israel zum Beispiel wie viel kann
besseres Beispiel ein hingewiesen und
sagte guck mal dieses dieses unglaublich
vertrocknete Stück Land dass man den 48
gegeben hat ja was die daraus gemacht
haben das eine Erfolgsgeschichte in
Sachen Bewässerung die exportieren
mittlerweile Wasser ja und das
kontrastiert zum Beispiel unglaublich
mit diesem Rinnsal das heute der Jordan
ist ja der der für mich als als jemanden
der so katholisch geprägt worden ist für
mich war der Jordan ein riesiger Fluss
und Johannes der Täufer und weiß er der
Fluss überhaupt und irgendwann stand ich
vor diesem Fluss standst oder was weiß
ich nicht aber da steht so breit wie
dieser Tisch war die redensartan gehen
eine ganz andere Bedeutung ist nur ein
Schritt wirklich wirklich ja kannst du
kannst du rüber ganz entspannt und das
meinte und da siehst du halt da gibt es
ein echtes Problem will ich damit sagen
in dieser Region im Nahen Osten dort und
dann gibt es aber auf der anderen Seite
diese Erfolgsgeschichte und wir Menschen
wenn wir uns anstrengen dann ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob das gelingt aber ich
finde wir sollten es zumindest versuchen
und das ist das was ich eigentlich sagen
wollte klar und deswegen geht's doch
darum und da kommen wir jetzt zu einem
Thema aber dass wir in dieser Woche auch
gesprochen haben Richard wie schulst du
sozusagen die Urteilsfähigkeit junger
Leute genau das ist das Wichtigste
überhaupt und noch schöner wäre sie so
zur Schulen dass sie wenn sie später mal
Journalisten werden nicht verloren geht
also dass die dauerhaft dass die
dauerhaft erhalten bleibt im Grunde
genommen sind das ja Dinge die im
Lehrplan stehen was macht man denn im
Deutschunterricht man lernt einen
Kommentar zu unterscheiden von einer
Nachricht das ist ganz normal so
Mittelstufe Deutschunterricht ja man
lernt differenziert zu analysieren und
argumentieren und in die den Kernaussage
eines Textes herauszuarbeiten ja
Kontexte zu verstehen und das kann ja
nicht sein dass diese Fähigkeit dann
nachher wieder verloren geht und ich
denke mal vielleicht wird sie in der
Schule alles in allem immer noch zu
wenig trainiert weil die komplexer die
Welt wird ja diese diese Welt in der
Orientierung ja immer schwieriger wird
weil ja unendlich viel Information aber
eben genauso viel Desinformationen zur
Verfügung steht sie Schulung der
Urteilskraft somit das Wichtigste
überhaupt was Schulen Kindern beibringen
kann so und da kommen wir jetzt zu der
Frage die dir mal ein ganzes Buchwert
war gutes Buch übrigens über über
Bildung
wo du in so einer kleinen Szene
beschreibst wie ein Lehrer die
Kreativität eines kleinen Mädchens ein
fiktives Beispiel
erstickt ja wie geht die Geschichte ja
das ist ich übernehme diese Geschichte
ne dass ich übernehme die von von
Robinson ach okay der der so der
bildungspapst in England ist schreibt
das auch dazu dass das sozusagen das
sind übrigens wichtig ist und erzählt
also Anna malt ja einer malt und dann
kommt der Lehrer und sagt was meinst Du
denn da und er sagt Anna ich male die
lieben Gott na sagte Lehrer ja aber da
weißt doch keiner wieder aussieht und
einer sagt ja warten sie noch 5 Minuten
dann wissen Sie
und das Schöne ist jetzt ein Satz der
von mir stammt ja Kreativität ist das
was man einsetzt wenn man nicht genau
weiß was dabei rauskommt richtig und die
Schule ist schön gesagt so organisiert
das immer schon klar ist was dabei
rauskommen soll nämlich das was im
Lehrplan steht oder was erwartet wird
oder was in diesen 40 oder 60 Punkten
die ein Lehrer hat um eine Arbeit zu
begutachten was vorher festgelegt worden
ist
und das ist im Grunde genommen ein
Überbleibsel aus einer Systemarchitektur
von Schulen aus dem 19 Jahrhundert wo
die Aufgabe von Schulen darin bestand
einer Arbeiter und Angestellten
Gesellschaft passende Arbeitskräfte zur
Verfügung zu stellen wir kommen aber
heute in eine Welt wo immer mehr Leute
nicht als klassische Arbeiter oder
Angestellter Arbeiten werden wo sie sich
ihren Weg durch das Leben selbst suchen
müssen wo sie vielleicht drei oder vier
verschiedene Sachen im Leben machen
vielleicht noch mehr wo wir keine
stromlinienförmigen Biografien haben
sondern bastelbiografien genau und dazu
passt diese Schule nicht mehr genau das
ist das ist halt der Punkt wenn man sich
das mal überlegt ich habe vor einiger
Zeit mal bei harari rumgelesen und ich
weiß auch der hat sich darüber lustig
gemacht und sagte Schule ist ja heute
eigentlich immer noch so mit in der
Stadt steht irgendwo ein großes Gebäude
ja und da drin gibt es ganz viele Räume
die sind im Grunde alle gleich und da
drin stehen die alle immer die gleichen
Stühle und die immer gleichen Tafel und
gleichen Schränke an der Wand und dann
klingelt's morgens um acht und da laufen
dort 30 Kinder rein und die sind alle
exakt so alt wie der jeweilige
Sitznachbar ja und aus deren Wahrnehmung
ist es dann so dann betreten einfach im
Laufe von so einem Vormittag
verschiedene Menschen immer wieder
diesen Raum der eine erzählt die was
über Geographie der andere was über
Geschichte der nächste was über
Mathematik und dann gehen die wieder
raus das war's das ist so wie wie lernen
nicht funktioniert richtig ja
genau darauf wollte ich gerade hinaus
sag mal das Vorbild war das Militär okay
ne also die preußischen Schulen sind
nach dem Vorbild mit dem Preußen alles
nach dem Vorbild des Militärs gemacht
das heißt also alle werden mit sechs
gezogen
Alter genau ja und alle machen dieselbe
Grundausbildung genau so dass die
Grundschule und dann später
wird absolut ich dachte immer ich finde
das immer preußischen Sozialismus
wirklich ja und dann nachher wir werden
werden die Schulen dann aus der
differenziert die Volksschule ja war die
ganz normale Wehrdienst ja die Gefreiten
Laufbahn quasi und ich werde weiter
bitte ja
und wenn man Realschule das war die
Unteroffizierslaufbahn genau und das
Gymnasium war die offizierslauf weiter
und man braucht nur wenig Offiziere so
war das ja damals früher macht also
wenige Anwälte und Ärzte ja und Leute
die eine Regierung arbeiteten und
deswegen sollten das nur ganz ganz
wenige schaffen ja und die Realschule
das war die Schreibstube das war ja
tatsächlich sozusagen die klassische
Aufgabe der Realschule war für für
geistige Routinearbeit auszubilden und
das haben wir von der Systemarchitektur
immer noch wir haben heute ganz andere
Lehrpläne und da stehen so viele
wunderschöne Dinge drin lernen und also
sowas ja aber die Systemarchitektur die
ist immer noch dieser größere
Sozialismus nach militärischen Vorbild
so und wenn man wenn man jetzt mal
überlegt ne aus weil du gerade sagst aus
welcher Zeit das kommt ich meine das
kommt doch aus einer Zeit in der es ja
selbst zu meiner Zeit in der Grundschule
ich hatte ein völlig anderen Zugang zu
Wissen als es Kinder heute haben meine
da war es bei mir in der Schule war es
schon wichtig dass man maximal viel
Wissen und Fakten und einfach schlichte
Zeug und zahlen und meinetwegen auch
noch Glocke vermittelt hat
und wenn ich ich kenne das auch so von
Reisen nach Afrika wenn wenn wenn so so
afrikanische Diktatoren wenn die
versuchen ihr Volk im Griff zu halten
was tun Sie sie schneiden es von Wissen
und von Bildung an sie halten die Leute
schlicht künstlich doof aber jetzt hat
sich doch und haben sich doch die
Verhältnisse komplett auf den Kopf
gestellt das geht ja nicht mehr selbst
wenn du hierhin bist selbst wenn du
Putin bist bist du nicht mehr in der
Lage angesichts der Fülle an
Informationen die überall und jederzeit
verfügbar ist und die sich alle paar
Jahre auch verdoppelt bist du nicht mehr
in der Lage egal wie ausgeklügelt ein
System ist die Leute davon abzuschneiden
das heißt du machst etwas anderes der
Sensor der Vergangenheit hat die Leute
von Informationen entkoppelt der Zen
soll der Gegenwart stellt das
Information dagegen so ja und das heißt
die Bombardierung von alepper und das
was da passiert und dann sorgt die
russische täuffabrik dafür dass nur
einen Klick weiter die Fake News dazu
sind
haben wir gar nicht war ganz jemand
anderer und am Ende immer die Amerikaner
das heißt auch da sind wir da was Schule
angeht darauf vorbereitet sind wir
vorbereitet damit umzugehen weil die
Schule die dir die wir beide gerade
beschreiben das ist eine Schule die
darauf ausgerichtet ist einfach
Schillers Glocke Fakten Zahlen darum
funktioniert
es wird heute viel viel weniger in der
Schule auswendig gelernt als früher
kennst du eigentlich ja das ist meine
spannende Frage also ich glaube ich
glaube diese Kritik am auswendig lernen
die teile ich nicht ich auch die Frage
ist was man auswendig lernen also ich
bring mal die Beispiele also bei uns war
das z.B zum Erdkundebuch ja da gibt's
dann 17 Schuljahr Kiruna war der Erzberg
im Norden das sind dann Corona die Stadt
in Nordschweden
und in Korona und so weiter so sichern
interessantes Thema ja aber die Aufgabe
total es gibt nichts was 13-jährige mehr
interessiert nein das ist nicht der ich
finde es wirklich interessant ja aber
dann kriegt man dann sieben acht Seiten
im Erdkundebuch und dann schreibt man
Test so und wenn man in diesem
Augenblick die geistige Kapazität hat
sich auf den Erzberg im Norden zu
konzentrieren und sich nicht die ganze
Zeit an seine Mitschülerin denkt ja was
bei mir ein riesiges Problem in dem
Alter war ja oder oder an Fußball
spielen am Nachmittag oder wie auch
immer ja und und tausend andere Dinge
die man im Kopf versetzt den Fall man
hatte die Kapazität frei dann kam es
drauf an wie intensiv man sich
vorbereitet so und dann gab es immer ein
paar fleißige in der Klasse ja die haben
das fast auswendig gelernt sie schreibt
in einer Eins und dann gibt es
diejenigen die mal flüchtig reingeguckt
oder Wesentliche zu erfassen die haben
eine vier geschrieben so so und dann
könnte man jetzt heute mal beim Abi
treffen ja was ist das bei mir wie viel
Jahre 30 wie viel Jahrzehnte seitdem
verges mal fragen wer erinnert sich noch
daran er wird wahrscheinlich einer
Meister sein du dann stellt man sich die
Frage dann stellt man sich die Frage
warum hat man diese Veranstaltung
überhaupt jeden Tag gemacht genau so das
ist sozusagen nicht auswendig lernen
aber es ist sich mit etwas zu
beschäftigen so routinemäßig weil man
weiß und danach kommt die Mathearbeit
und so weiter so bleibt nichts hängen so
geht das nicht auswendig lernen finde
ich eigentlich ganz gut weil das trägt
man ja dann mit sich rum ja und
vielleicht sogar sein Leben lang wenn
man das mit Schmackes auswendig gelernt
hat die Frage ist nur was lernt man
auswendig wenn man zum Beispiel in der
Theater AG ist ja und man lernt eine
Rolle und kann sich dann vielleicht
wirklich 20 Jahre noch an irgendein
Monolog oder ein Dialog erinnern dann
ist das doch was was man lebendig im
Kopf hat ja aber das mit dem
Erdkundebuch wo es einfach nur darum
gegen seine Pflicht zu erfüllen ja was
also ohne Leidenschaft gelernt ist ich
ja das bringt nichts weil sie hat einen
Erdkunde Lehrer deine in der im
Gymnasium dann später deinen in Brixen
im vincentinum tolles Gymnasium ähm da
kommen ganz viele Südtiroler die man
dann die man dann später so in der
Politik und so weiter gesehen hat die
kommen fast alle daher und da hatten wir
einen Erdkunde Lehrer der hatte so ein
Fetisch die bundessta Amerikas
die mussten wir auswendig lernen und es
war die Hölle und ich habe es so gehasst
aber du kannst sie heute genau und als
ich später durch die USA gereist bin war
es natürlich interessant zu sehen ja
okay wo ist denn das und stimmt das denn
was er damals immer so erzählt hat und
es gab durchs auswendig lernen ja
natürlich Dinge die ich im Hinterkopf
hatte die ich dann direkt mit der
Realität abgleichen konnte Kiruna genau
das gleiche ich war mal was du mein Kero
nein ich ich okay dann sage ich Dir
jetzt warum du das auswendig gelernt
hast
Schweden ja ich war da mehrfach und erst
letzten April wieder da gibt es diesen
riesigen Erzberg denn im Norden ja von
dem du von dem du gerade heißt er genau
das weiß ich noch so und da falls der
heute noch so heißt ich will keine
Ahnung auf jeden Fall kommt da ein
großer Teil des Stahls der die deutsche
Autoindustrie braucht kommt daher heute
noch ja ja definitiv die beliefern die
beliefern immer noch Eisenerz aus Kiruna
ist immer die Sache absolut ganz wichtig
die haben Kunden in der ganzen Welt hat
mir der eine Chef da oder der der Chef
der Presseabteilung damals erzählt im
Schneetreiben standen wir darum in der
Polarnacht haben uns beide den Hintern
abgefroren und er erzählte mit
leuchtenden Augen wie wichtig Kiruna ist
auch unter anderem für die Autoindustrie
weil das eben besonders hochwertig ist
darum geht's und ja ich pass auf der
Stoff an sich ist interessant
das ist das Ding das ist eine Stadt muss
und die lebt nur von diesem Berg ja und
dann wohnst du dein so ein Hotel und
nachts um zwei jede Nacht ich glaube es
ist zwei macht einmal Krawumm aber nicht
Kavum so wie eine Explosion direkt neben
dir sondern in 1000 Meter Tiefe das
heißt so ein dummes Groll und der ganze
Berg die ganze Bude das ganze kleine
Hotel dein ganzes Zimmer alles so bebt
leicht vor sich hin und du weißt es
haben die da unten wieder Tonnen
Eisenerz in die Luft gejagt ich habe ihn
gefragt warum man das so machen ist ja
Lärmbelästigung ja nachts immer dieses
Theater und er sagte ja und da ist die
Mine so leer wie niemals sonst am Tag
das quasi keiner drin das alles
automatisiert und und dann und dann
jagen die da irgendwie Eisen oder
Gestein in die Luft und bauen dann holen
dann das Eisenerz raus und treiben diese
Mine immer tiefer unter die Stadt rein
was jetzt dazu führt dass sie große
Teile der Stadt verlegen müssen und
unter anderem auch diese wunderschöne
alte Kirche die es da gibt so eine ganz
schöne will die empfehle ich sehr immer
so eine nordische Kirche uralt Kiruna so
und das zweite ist die die Migranten
Routen der Rentiere verändern sich
dadurch das sind aber
du weißt ja Rentiere muss ich dir als
Zoologen nicht erklären sind ja halbwild
ne halb domestiziert glaube so das heißt
du kommst da schon ran und die kommen
auch nicht Migranten ne sondern
Migration ja genau
und das gibt's eben in Nord Europa eben
auch ja und das Problem ist dass du
natürlich Areale dann anfängst
abzusperren die Mine das eine
gleichzeitig aber auch Forstwirtschaft
haben die plötzlich das Problem ihre
Routen zu finden und verlaufen sich
verirren sich finden sich nicht mehr zu
Recht das Interessante ist faszinierend
du selbst der Züchter weiß nicht wann
sich seine Tiere auf den Weg machen
irgendwann im Herzen genau
und unter irgendwann im Frühjahr kommen
sie dann wieder zurück ja das ist total
faszinierend das zu sehen und und er
könnte jetzt stundenlang zufrieden ja
aber wenn wir einen Klassenausflug
gemacht hätten ja hätte ich das alles
erzählt nach Kiruna dann hätten
wahrscheinlich alle in der Klasse die
sich noch an den Erzberg erinnert genau
da bin ich ziemlich sicher also wenn
sich das mit Anschauung gefüllt hätte
richtig nur so wie es damals war wurde
es nicht so richtig anschauen ja und da
stand auch nicht drin dass die deutsche
Automobilindustrie das ernst her kriegt
das eine Günther ja auch Frage für eine
halbe Million ja ja
definitiv die sind wichtig das ist so
mega Man könnte das mit viel anschauen
so toll vermitteln dass ich das jeder
dann merkt und das entscheidende für die
Schule ist ja nie was hat jemand mal
irgendwann gelernt oder was mache ich
wie gut kann ich rechnen im siebten
Schuljahr ist die unwichtigste Frage der
Welt die wichtigste Frage der Welt ist
wie gut kann ich rechnen wenn ich zehn
Jahre aus der Schule raus bin und das
wird nie gemessen sondern gemessen wird
ja immer nur diese Altersvergleich oder
Gleichaltrigen und da wissen wir ja alle
alle Mädchen sind meistens schneller
entwickelt als Jungens und so weiter dem
wird ja nicht Rechnung getragen sondern
es geht ja immer nur nach Alter und
damit wird natürlich der Individualität
der Schüler Persönlichkeiten nicht
Rechnung getragen oder auch nicht dem
Konzept der Schule ja die vielleicht
sagen ja wir gehen beim Mathe lassen wir
es mal etwas langsamer angehen als ihr
so aber nachher werden wir steiler genau
dieser Gestaltungsspielraum der ist ja
nicht da genau aber trotzdem jetzt
deutsche Schule ich meine äh ging jetzt
um die vierte Klasse konkret gab es eine
neue Untersuchung neuen Report riesen
Aufschrei überall alle total entsetzt
Viertklässler können nicht mehr richtig
rechnen können nicht mehr richtig lesen
das Niveau wird ständig und beständig
schlechter sind heute schlechter als vor
zehn Jahren und wir beide die Eltern
erinnern sich ja wir müssen vor zehn
Jahren gab es die Klage auch schon immer
schon also seit es Schüler gibt jeder
Generation
aber diesmal scheint auch tatsächlich
sozusagen also tatsächlich kommen da
offensichtlich viele Kinder nicht mehr
richtig mit übrigens das erschreckend
traurig so schlecht geworden ist ja die
Körpermotorik wird immer immer
schlechter wundert sich das weil die
Kinder nicht mehr auf der Straße wundert
dich das jetzt wundert mich nicht aber
das finde ich noch viel erschreckender
weil wir so viele Berufe haben wo man
das können muss ja egal ob du Schreiner
oder Zahnarzt wirst ja das ist genau das
was man ganz ganz ganz viel braucht und
was in der Schule ja nicht mit
vermittelt wird nichts gemacht wird
manchmal gibt's noch Werken in der
Schule aber auch nicht unbedingt also
wir vernachlässigen den Körper ne wir
wir wir denken der Körper ist nur dazu
da den Kopf von einem Klassenzimmer ins
andere zu tragen das ist aber es ist
schon merkwürdig wenn du die auf der
anderen Seite anguckst was
Körperlichkeit aussehen wie fit bin ich
wie gut sich wie dünn bin ich dieser
ganze Irrsinn der sich da so warm wird
krassen Widerspruch absolut das was ich
mal angeregt habe in der Grundschule
meines Sohnes ne wenn der aus der Schule
kam dann hat er sich aufs Bett
gestellt und es gehüpft gehüpft ja und
so eine halbe Stunde lang sich also
quasi müde gehüpft woraus man ja sofort
ersehen kann dass dieses Bedürfnis nach
körperlicher Bewegung in der Schule
zwanghaft ja erst wie so eine Hecke da
beschnitten worden und ich hatte
angeregt ob die Schule nicht tobräume
einführen kann bei Toben auf dem
Schulungen ist negativ besetzt wenn ich
jetzt aber so riesige trampolin-räume
habe oder so wie gummizellen ja wo man
da so wirklich mal probieren kann oder
was einfach um diese ganze Energie
rauszulassen wurde dann damit
beantwortet dass dafür ja ein
Aufsichtspersonen da sein müssen die
nicht da sind ja und dann wurde noch
andere formaljuristische Gründe gefunden
warum man das nicht machen kann
ich sage dir immer wieder es ist nicht
die Politik das größte Problem ja es
gibt auch ganz viele Lehrer mit guten
Ideen die viel verändern wollen und
Schulleiter gibt es auch und
Schulleiterinnen da liegt nicht das
Problem das größte Problem ist unsere
Schulen ersticken durch die
Kultusbürokratie
das ist jetzt wirklich das ist das ist
das was ich am wenigsten bewegen wenn
man als Kultusminister anfangen würde
und sagt jetzt machen wir mal andere
Schulen mit Länder haben ja eine Ruhe
Hoheit extrem zu machen gerade Frau
stark Watzinger in der Sendung mit in
der Stadtstraße die
Bundesbildungsminister die hat er
relativ wenig zu sein das ist das
Tragische daran unter merkst doch dass
das funktioniert einfach nicht das geht
so nicht weiter schlicht oder
Föderalismus hat Nachteile hat auch ein
paar Vorteile ja weil man sozusagen mit
einem kleinere Bundesland relativ
schnell die veränderten die Dinge
verändern kann wenn man jetzt weiß ich
im Saarland oder in Berlin was verändern
wollen aber das große Problem liegt
einfach darin dass man ausgebremst würde
vom eigenen Apparat bei für für die
Kultus Bürokratie bedeutet das
Unsicherheit genau Neuland ja juristisch
ist das alles hochbedingtlich da wird
irgendwas verändert Biologieunterricht
vielleicht wenn es um Blätter geht mal
im Wald dann fehlt die zweite
Aufsichtspersonen da fehlt einem Arzt
auf dem Kopf das ist schon wieder alles
tut wieder zurückgetreten wir haben
Angst Stillstand in der Schule und man
muss auch dazu sagen auch wenn ich mich
damit unbeliebt mache aber
kultusbürokrate wird man selten dadurch
dass man überschäumt vor Kreativität und
neuen Ideen es gibt solche ganz ganz
bestimmte wir wollen ja niemanden
beleidigen aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit
dass sie sich in großen Scharen in der
Kultusbürokratie wiederfinden ist nicht
ist relativ ja einer meiner besten
Freunde Martin liebe Grüße an der Stelle
ist lange zeitlehrer gewesen wäre ist
jetzt leider im Ruhestand und es ist
traurig da müsste eigentlich noch 50
Jahre weiter machen das ist genauso ein
Lehrer ein großartiger Lehrer immer
gewesen und dieselben einmal kurz
Augenbraue heben ja hat bei mir schon
funktioniert der Jahre später bei meinen
Kinder genauso ja extrem interessant der
hat so eine natürlich
autoritätungsberuf
wirklich
sagen ein guter Lehrer ist im Regelfall
also jedenfalls bei solange Unterricht
läuft wie wir ihn kennen ein guter
Entertainer genau weil die wichtigste
Qualifikation für ein Lehrer ist nicht
und das ein riesiger Irrtum dass er
Kinder besonders gerne mag das ist ein
Irrtum ich würde sagen die Lehrer fand
ich am meisten gelernt habe waren dafür
nicht berühmt und berüchtigt sondern ich
ist schön wenn er Kinder macht finde ich
großartig ist nicht das wichtigste weil
wir hatten Lehrer die mochten Kinder ja
aber die Kinder mochten den Unterricht
trotzdem nicht sondern dass die
wichtigste Qualifikation eines Lehrers
ist dass man ihm gerne zuhörst klar
sonst kann man nichts lernen das war und
es gibt Menschen die verfügen über diese
Gabe und es gibt andere Menschen die
können die auch mit viel Mühe nicht
richtig lernen das was du gerade sagtest
Richard weil ich Martin kurz erwähnt
habe der hat mir das beschrieben wie
sich das im Laufe der Jahrzehnte da
reden wir jetzt von Italien ne
italienisches Schulsystem verändert hat
wie Lehrer immer ängstlicher wurden war
quasi gefühlt immer auch der der Anwalt
direkt mit auf dem Hof steht das heißt
auf dem Baum klettern war dann
irgendwann einfach nicht mehr weil
könnte ja runterfallen könnte ja was
passieren kommt direkt der Anwalt der
Eltern und dann hast du ein richtiges
Problem richtig und das das ist
ehrlich gesagt eine katastrophale
Entwicklung du kennst jetzt bei Jul der
hat mal gesagt auf die Frage wie man das
machen sollte sagte lasst die Kinder auf
die Bäume klettern ja und dann und dann
wenn sie runterfallen sagte ich fragt
die nie ob sie runterfahren ich sage
auch nie das ist gefährlich ich sage den
immer pass auf kletter hoch und dann
sagt mir was du von da oben siehst das
war nicht gut das ist das ist das ist
der Ansatz aber der Punkt ist trotzdem
Richard du hast diese Studie dazu muss
man wissen Deutschland gibt
vergleichsweise viel Geld für Bildung
aus ja
Wirtschaftskraft Deutschland
dann hast du deutsche Lehrer also immer
gesagt wir kriegen keine guten Lehrer
weil die so schlecht bezahlt werden
stimmt auch nicht die zweite beste
Bezahlung allerdings
mit mit riesen Abstand zu Luxemburg so
also Luxemburg ist ja nur eine ganz
andere Liga ist so ne ja also da also
das auch einige Nachteile dann könnt ja
denken hey wir kriegen die besten
dadurch dass wir Lehrer gut bezahlen was
den Luxemburg dazu geführt ist eine der
wenigen Studiengänge die man in
Luxemburg selber machen kann
normalerweise bedeutet ja für die
vielsprachigen Luxemburger man geht ins
Ausland man studiert in Frankreich und
studiert in Deutschland und diejenigen
die zu Hause bei Mama bleiben die werden
Lehrer war das das einzige was man zu
Hause werden kann die müssen nie die
Welt gesehen haben ja alle anderen
Luxemburger die akademische Ausbildung
machen müssen
nicht raus und dann ist natürlich dieser
Anreiz das Beamtenstatus ist gepaart mit
dem hohen Einkommen nicht das was
unbedingt die hungrigsten Talent hat
aber was auch interessant finde ich es
Schulsystem wird der häufig gelobt und
Finnland verdienen Lehrer deutlich
weniger aber es gibt eine sehr hohe
Nachfrage also es gibt immer mehr
Bewerber in Finnland als es eigentlich
offene Posten gibt die Schule mehr Spaß
also so Estland z.B hat in in solchen
und ähnlichen Tests schneidet nur
richtig guter Matte und andere Dinge die
haben aber ein ziemlich kleinen Etat für
für für für Schule und Bildung das heißt
am geldscheinst nicht nur zu liegen
Dänemark zum Beispiel dänemark hat total
interessant die sind ja so voll durch
digitalisiert das hat man bei Corona
schon gesehen wir haben enorm davon
profitiert die hatten eine government
und so weiter die hatten immer die Daten
die wir heute noch nicht haben also
Deutschland ist da wirklich Jahrzehnte
hinterher und in der Schule lernen mit
der mobilen Endgerät während wir darüber
reden jeden mit iPads auszustatten WLAN
und so weiter ist in Dänemark das Thema
bring mir um die weiß ja das hat sich
total durchgesetzt ja die bringen sehr
gut meine Schwester ist Lehrerin okay
2012 mein Buch geschrieben habe hat sie
das Korrektur gelesen und sie hat über
viele Dinge den Kopf geschüttelt ja weil
so vieles wo ich dass ich quasi als
Vision dargestellt habe in Dänemark
alles schon realisiert war ja 2012 also
wir haben hier ein Europa
unterschiedlicher Geschwindigkeiten
original ja was läuft dort besser
Richard das sind glaube ich ganz viele
verschiedene Faktoren also die
Digitalisierung wird fruchtbar
eingesetzt die Digitalisierung ist da
sehen wir uns auch eigentlich nicht dass
alle Heilmittel des Schulsystems
auch immer in der Debatte ja immer
Hardware wirklich gibt den Leuten iPad
und dann ist alles gut so so
funktioniert das ja wirklich also das
ist das eine das zweite ist in Dänemark
gehen natürlich viele Dinge und deswegen
auch die Schule sehr viel besser weil
das ein Land ohne Armut ist
das ist ja im Grunde genommen die
dänische Gesellschaft ist dadurch
gekennzeichnet dass es weniger reiche
gibt aber auch sehr wenige Arme also die
Anzahl der abgehängten ist sehr sehr
klein im Vergleich zu Deutschland
deswegen schneidest du bei
internationalen Vergleichstest immer gut
ab die finden übrigens auch ja das heißt
je mehr Mittelstand du hast und je
weniger Verlierer der Gesellschaft du
hast abgehängte du hast umso besser bist
du anschließend beim Test wird das Spiel
glaube ich eine ziemlich große Rolle
dabei und dann ist es einfach richtig
richtige Ideen können in einem Land mit
4 Millionen Einwohnern ganz schnell und
das ist so nun überlegt sich mal so viel
Einwohner wie Berlin ne hat Dänemark und
wenn wenn man sich einig ist was man
machen will dann kann man das ganz
schnell umsetzen und jetzt guckt ihr
Deutschland an mit 80 Millionen und mit
dem Föderalismus der Stärken hat aber
eben auch die großen Schwächen hat dass
du das eben nicht skalieren kannst so
was du da machst und welche Rolle spielt
da Richard in dem Zusammenhang die
Tatsache dass Deutschland einfach ein
echtes Einwanderungsland geworden ist
ich meine wenn du das so mit kriegst
40%, ne Grundschule sind haben
mittlerweile Migrationshintergrund hier
in Hamburg würde ich sagen an vielen
Stellen sogar mehr aber in Hamburg ist
interessanter Fall weil hier der der
Kultursenator Thies Rabe mit dem ich
mich immer fürchterlich gestritten habe
in der Sendung wegen Luftfilter an und
so weiter die kann da ein wenig in die
Gänge
ehemaliger Lehrer hat aber
offensichtlich einiges richtig gemacht
die haben diese Entwicklung schon vor
langer Zeit gesehen vor gut zehn Jahren
und haben angefangen systematisch
dagegen zu steuern das heißt Hamburg
schneidet in diesem Test während alle
anderen schlecht ab erstaunlich gut an
die Entwicklung in den Schulen auch
erstaunlich gut
Migrantenkinder Spracherwerb und so
weiter erstaunlich gut die gehen ganz
gezielt sozusagen gegen dieses die ganze
Problematik an und erzielen damit dann
auch Überraschung wirklich großer Folge
das finde ich interessant also
ist ja warum geht das kleines Bundesland
ich würde sagen politischer Wille da ist
jemand anders
also das gleiche in Hamburg zu machen
oder in Nordrhein-Westfalen zu machen
ist nicht dasselbe das ist wahr aber am
Ende bricht sich ja trotzdem runter auf
eine kommunale Ebene hast also Schule
wichtig ist die zentrale Frage nach den
Migranten Kindern zwischen erstmal gibt
es natürlich auch hoch unterschiedliche
ne das muss man klar sagen aber es gibt
natürlich unter dem Migranten Kindern
einen recht hohen Anteil wo
Sprachprobleme vorliegen ja oder wo die
Elternhäuser nicht im gleichen Maße
coachen oder unterstützen können wie bei
vielen Deutschen nicht bei allen
deutschen muss man auch sagen das ist in
der Tat so und ich habe in meinem Buch
damals 2012 schon angeregt ob wir nicht
eine allgemeine Kindergartenpflicht so
einführen sollten wo man dann mit drei
Jahren hingeht und
damals übrigens angeregt auch durch
Luxemburg wo ist das gibt
und es gibt mehrere Länder gehst du mit
drei in Kindergarten gehst du mit drei
Kinder
Luxemburg haben sehr ähnliches Bild also
da gibt's das und in Deutschland
scheitert das im Grunde genommen ein
zwei Kategorien eine einscheitert es
nicht aber die sind nicht dafür das ist
natürlich wenn du Fundamentalist bist
oder religiöse extreme Überzeugungen
hast und so weiter möchtest du nicht
dass dein Kind richtig da infiltrieren
lassen
in Frage stellt aber am stärksten
dagegen sind in Deutschland besser
verdienen der Elternhäuser wo die Mütter
zu Hause sind und sich um die Kinder
kümmern
also das ist die viel stärkere
politische Klientel die das nicht will
nur sagt die so soll mein Kind in so
einem blöden Kindergarten gehen ich kann
da sie auch zu Hause mich um die kümmern
und machen und kriegt vielleicht eine
bessere Bildung und so weiter die wollen
das nicht und dann kann man ja sagen man
macht diese Kindergartenpflicht aber man
macht nur einen relatives Minimum an
Pflichtstunden dafür ja die müssen jetzt
nicht die ganzen Vormittag unbedingt
denken aber aus Solidaritätsprinzip
müsste man das eigentlich machen weil
das wichtigste ist einfach es kann nicht
sein und das wird jeder
Grundschullehrerin jeder
Grundschullehrer besteht bestätigen es
gibt Migranten Kinder die kommen mit Sex
in die Schule sprechen kann deutsch und
das meine ich so und diesen Nachteil es
geht holen hochbegabte Kinder auf aber
normal Begeisterung Kinder einfach nicht
und dann weiß man schon von Anfang an
die werden da nicht besonders
erfolgreich registrieren und das kann
nicht sein also jeder der in Deutschland
in der Grundschule eingeschult worden
ist und auch schon ein paar Jahre in
Deutschland vorher gelebt hat muss die
Sprache sprechen das muss ein ganz
wichtiges Ziel im Kindergarten sein
und nach wie vor ist das nicht der Fall
und dir das wird seit 20 Jahren beklagt
bis irre ja vor allem wenn du wenn du
mal überlegst ich ich jemand in Hamburg
ich glaube Thies Rabe sogar hat das hat
das berichtet und sagte naja überlegt
doch mal vorlesen also genau um die
Fähigkeit ist gerade ging auch in dieser
Untersuchung ja lesen wird immer
schlechter okay warum ist das so naja
die Kinder kriegen zwar vorgelesen
lernen lesen in der Grundschule gehen
dann nach Hause treffen dann dort aber
auf eine Familie in der nicht vorgelesen
wird und in der schon gar nicht in
Deutsch vorgelesen wird so woher soll
der lesen lernen kann ich dir sagen es
gibt eine Organisation in Deutschland
die heißt Mentor deren Schirmherr bin
ich seit über 10 Jahren ja und diese
Organisation macht genau das heißt da
gehen überwiegend in der Grundschule
manchmal auch in der Unterstufe Leute
dahin die werden so ein klein bisschen
vorbereitet auf diese Aufgabe und dann
lesen die zusammen mit Kindern
das heißt also das heißt wenn Kontakt
zur Schule auf ja die Lehrerin sagt guck
mal hier der kann nicht lesen nicht
richtig und so weiter und diese
Betreuungssituation die da entsteht die
führen hat ist sehr sehr erfolgreich
also es ist wirklich eine ganz große
Erfolgsgeschichte mittlerweile gibt es
Mentor in jeder deutschen größeren Stadt
wer macht das dann sind das Leute die
vielleicht schon im Rentenalter sind
sind Leute haben Alter ja klar ich hatte
mal ich habe mal angeregt was auch
spannend wäre weil diese die sind mehr
Frauen als Männer aber es gibt den ein
oder anderen Jungen mit
Migrationshintergrund der bräuchte
eigentlich ein jungen Mann der braucht
nicht eine ältere ja dich dich zum
Beispiel könnte der gebrauchen oder der
könnte auch dass ich immer sage bei
Firmen ja also bei Banken oder so stellt
doch die Leute einfach ein paar Stunden
in der Woche frei dass sie das machen im
Rahmen der Ausbildung
ja weil wenn der so ein richtig cooler
Typ ist mit einem coolen Bad und cool
drauf und so weiter und bis 22 oder so
ja und du du greifst dir jetzt den
achtjährigen oder neunjährigen und sagt
er meiner kriegst du noch hin der hat ja
noch eine andere Anspruch und da
empfiehlt es an Leuten und es wäre sehr
gut wenn Firmen das viel stärker machen
würden und dass das also wie gesagt im
Rahmen der Ausbildung jemand freistet
was man da an wertvolle Macht über das
Lesen ja über das Lesen erschließt man
sich die Welt man scheitert ja an allem
wenn man nicht lesen kann oder wenn man
langsam liest oder wenn einem Lesen
schwer fällt oder wenn man nicht gerne
liest ich meine lesen ist denken mit
Fremden Gehirn ja keine bessere Schulung
ja für die für die Intelligenz und die
Sensibilität gegenüber der Welt als lese
weißt du der Punkt ist noch mal zum
Schluss Richard die Welt um uns herum
ändert sich ja so dramatisch wie
vielleicht noch nie in der Geschichte
der Menschheit ja dramatisch schnell ja
also wenn du was sie nicht wenn du vor
100 Jahren
zur Schule gegangen bist also das
bestand ja immer alles sozusagen aus
zwei aus zwei Teilen wenn du so willst
ja also Ausbildung und dann Beruf und
dann war die Wahrscheinlichkeit in
diesem Beruf bis zum Rentenalter oder
bis zum Ende deines Lebens dass dann
auch schon mit 40 oder so erreicht war
drin zu bleiben die war mit hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit war das so aber ein
Kind das heute auf die Welt kommt
das lebt den 100 Jahren noch genauso und
ist in 80 Jahren wahrscheinlich durch
medizinischen Fortschritt noch ein sehr
aktives Mitglied dieser Gesellschaft und
wenn in Berufen arbeiten die es jetzt
noch gar nicht gibt genau das meine ich
und wenn du dir aber fragst und sagst
pass auf worauf soll die denn die Schule
vorbereiten welche Welt wird das sein
vor 100 Jahren wusste man das da warst
du oder noch weiter zurück da warst du
Bauer oder Weber es war oder Adliger
genau aber heute wie sieht die Welt in
100 Jahren wie sieht die Welt in 50
Jahren aus wer weiß das niemand kann das
seriös sagen das heißt wenn das
sozusagen die die Gegebenheiten sind die
sich völlig verändern dann ändert sich
doch auch die Aufgabe von Schule
komplett fundamental ja das Wichtigste
sozusagen die die die die Fähigkeit zu
Anpassung aber wieder die Anpassung oder
die die Fähigkeit sozusagen kreativ auf
neue Situation zu reagieren ja also die
zentrale Aufgabe der Schule selbst man
ja also man wird nicht mehr so leicht in
irgendeine Schublade reinspringen können
und dann in dem entlang da drin verstaut
liegen sondern man muss sich sein sein
Parcours durch das Leben immer wieder
und immer wieder neu suchen so und dafür
braucht man das was wir vorhin gesagt
haben eine sehr gute Urteilskraft eine
sehr gute Selbsteinschätzung
sehr gut ist es wenn man sehr gut mit
anderen Menschen umgehen kann also ein
hohes Maß sozialer Kompetenz hat mit
allem was dazugehören nicht nur lieb
sein sondern vielleicht auch lustig sein
ja also mit mit mit Niederlagen umgehen
Stress verarbeiten können resilient sein
also das sind ja alles das ist
eigentlich jener Bereich der früher bei
den Kopf Noten mal abgedeckt werden
sollte wo es um betragen und Fleiß geht
ja da geht es jetzt sozusagen um diese
Tugenden und statt dieser Tugenden
müssten eigentlich alles das was ich
aufgezählt habe ich will nicht dass
dafür Noten verteilt werden aber es
müsste sozusagen das übergeordnete
Bildungsziel sein natürlich muss man
auch heute Fach Wissen vermitteln das
ist alles richtig aber das was hier
Selbstmanagement vermittelt werden kann
und das kann man ja nicht
Selbstmanagement vermittelt man ja nicht
dadurch dass ich in Lehrer hinstellt an
die Tafel schreibt welche sieben
Eigenschaften man haben kann um das zu
machen sondern das kann man ja nur durch
erproben lernen genau das gehört zu den
Dingen ich sage auch immer also sein
Sexualverhalten lernt man nicht im
Sexualkunde Atlas ja also indem man den
auswendig lernt und dann anschließend
weiß wie es geht ja man musste schon
vorher das ist doch die Wahrheit du
wusstest vorher bevor ich den
Sexualkunde Atlas gehe genau hast du
doch von erwähnt wofür du dich
interessiert hast in der Grundschule
schon ja also bei uns war das
tatsächlich wir hatten einen sehr hübsch
illustrierten Sexualkunde Atlas bei uns
zu Hause da wurden wir tatsächlich im
Grundschulleiter aufgeklärt ja ja und
der hatte also so schöne pastellfarbene
Bilder und so weiter ja ja genau das war
jetzt auch nicht so ein linkes
Teufelszeug also es war unglaublich
unschuldig das hatte also völlig die
Anmutung eines bürgerlichen Bilderbuch
ist nach Paarung steht mir nun der Sinn
damit ich nicht mehr Single bin
[Musik]
das ganze um das Ganze zusammen erfassen
ich werde häufig gefragt was ich meinem
Sohn mit gebe auf dem Lebensweg und so
weiter was er werden soll oder so ja und
die Antwort ist total simpel ja tut das
wofür du brennst und die
Anforderung die ich an die Schule habe
ist wenn jemand für etwas brennt dass er
das nicht in seiner Schulzeit verliert
für etwas zu brennen da sind wir nämlich
wieder bei deinem schönen Beispiel vom
vom Anfang Richard und damit schließt
sich sozusagen der Kreis Anna die den
lieben Gott meint und in deiner
Geschichte gibt einer dann ja die schöne
Antwort dann warte noch mal fünf Minuten
dann weißt du wie der liebe Gott
aussieht ich sage dir bei dem Hinweis
des Lehrers der sagt weiß man doch gar
nicht wie der aussieht da sehe ich schon
diese extrem enttäuschen Augen von Anna
die eine sagt okay gut wenn man das
sowieso nicht weiß dann kann ja ja das
ist demotiviert und bist ein bisschen
Smart aber das ist wirklich interessant
weil du auch
ein Gedanke nur noch wenn du wenn du das
mal wirklich konkret zu Ende denkst ich
war vor einiger Zeit mit meinem Sohn im
Bulgarien unterwegs mit dem Land keine
Chance mich mit einem Händler dem ich
irgendwas abkaufen wollte zu einem für
ihn okay Preis und auch für mich okay
Preis ja ein Wort ein kleines Geschäft
machen ich konnte mich mit dem nicht
verständigen bis mir einfiel okay
Smartphone Google Übersetzer und dann
haben uns wunderbar war Preise
ausgetauscht ich habe einfach mein Text
rein geredet bulgarisch gedrückt und
zack in einer ferneren Zukunft in 50
Jahren vielleicht in 100 Jahren haben
wir vielleicht ein Chip im Kopf da haben
wir vielleicht alles Wissen von
Wikipedia haben wir vielleicht bereits
in unserem Hirn weil wir gar nicht
wissen was das mit der menschliche Küche
macht also ich habe nicht so richtig
sicher ob das die beste Idee der
Menschheit ist ja vielleicht nicht
Richard aber ich sag mal die technischen
Möglichkeiten weisen eindeutigen
Richtung geht dahin ja so das heißt
nicht mal mehr der Spracherwerb also
wenn du heute sagst China ist mega Markt
und ich Chinesisch lernen musst du
vielleicht gar nicht mehr in 50 Jahren
machst du das dann einfach so auch wenn
du nur guten Tag also ich kann die
positive Seite daran sehen aber ich kann
auch das Bild malen und mir jetzt
vorstellen also stell mal vor mit 18 19
wärst du irgendwo im Süden gewesen und
kommst in irgend spanischem Kneipe oder
ein Club oder eine Bar Tapas war und so
weiter ja und du kannst keinen Spanisch
ja du findest aber irgendwie das Essen
interessant und du findest dass da auch
irgendwie eine der Spanierin hat dir
sofort angetan und sowas alles ja darauf
kommt natürlich und das wäre alles seine
Motivation ja und dann möglichst ganz
schnell relativ viel Spanisch aufzubauen
und dich irgendwie zu orientieren zu
können und Teil des Ganzen zu sein und
du findest diese Sprache wunderbar die
du nicht verstehst und die sind großes
Geheimnis für dich und du nervst dich ja
an wenn du jetzt aber das ist nicht der
Spanierin ne sowohl als auch Sprache der
Spanierin und wenn du wenn du das ganze
jetzt aber nicht mehr brauchst sondern
einfach nur noch dein Handy hast ja und
dann hast du da anschließend da deine
Übersetzung und kannst dich dann
verständigen und so weiter ist natürlich
eine Menge Zauber aus ja würde ich sagen
gehe dann auch die eine oder andere
Tapas Bar heute in Spanien wo viele
junge Menschen drin sind ja und alle
gucken in ihr Smartphone so das ist die
Schattenseite ich will nicht sagen das
ist das eine ist besser als das andere
sondern das ist das große Geheimnis des
technischen Fortschritts besteht immer
darin dass er alte Probleme löst und
neue schafft richtig und es wird immer
etwas hinzugewonnen und mit allem was
wir dahin zu gewinnen verlieren und
weißt du okay guter Punkt Richard und
ich würde noch was ergänzen vielleicht
genauso wichtig umso wichtiger ist es zu
wissen was du willst ja und wer du bist
ja bei sonst wird dieses mächtige
Werkzeug ja etwas das Macht über dich
gewinnt ja und diese Zombies von denen
du gerade sprichst in diesen Tapas Bars
und auch in jeder deutschen
Fußgängerzone unterwegs sind die kennen
wir alle also die Frage ob er da noch
die Macht über Smartphone hat oder das
Smartphone längst die Macht über ihn
musst du nicht mehr stellen also würde
man doch sagen ist es eine wichtige
Aufgabe der Schule ja dabei zu helfen
souverän damit Technik umzugehen genau
was bedeutet du musst zum Beispiel was
du willst und wer du bist ja und was ich
schon immer angeregt habe ja das ist
meditationsunterricht in der Schule so
wer das macht ob das der Religionslehrer
macht oder der Sportlehrer ist mir
relativ egal es geht mir also nicht um
Weihrauch und Glöckchen geklingelt ja
sondern es geht darum die
fähigkeitsversammlung zu bewahren also
wir leben in einer in einer Gesellschaft
in der wir umzingelt sind von
aufmerksamkeitsäubern
aufmerksamkeits Raub steht nicht im
Strafgesetzbuch sollte
ist aber die größte Bedrohung für die
Entwicklung einer kindlichen und
Resilienz zu werden dagegen ich stelle
mir auch sowas vor der bekommen so
Lichtquellen von außen ja und man muss
sozusagen die ausblenden und sich
trotzdem also konzentrieren genau
sammeln bei sich sein richtig das alles
ist so wichtig dass wir das in der
Schule digital ja das ist mindestens
genauso wichtig wie zu versuchen ob man
man Handstand Überschlag oder sowas
hinkriegt sondern das ist eine
elementare Schlüsselqualifikation fürs
Leben also Richard vielen Dank und ich
sag mal so das schreit nach dem zweiten
Teil lass uns doch nächste Woche mal
konkret darüber reden ja was anders und
was besser wäre also wer überlegen uns
wenn wir schulen die sein würden und uns
überlegen würden was könnte eine gute
Schule sein ja und und im Hinterkopf
haben was ist auch schon alles gut es
gibt zum Beispiel dann wäre das
entspannter Aufgabe wir bauen uns eine
gute Schule sehr gut wunderbar
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF